ما قال على صحيفه كوميرسون الروسيه تصدر
الاخبار والعناوين اليوم فالصحيفه الروسيه
نشرت مقالا عنوانه اتصالات غير مرغوب فيها
الطلب من المسؤولين التخلص من هواتف ايفون
الامريكيه الصحيفه تقول نقلا عن مصادر في
الرئاسه لم تسميها ان مهلنا مهله منحت
لمسؤولين في الاداره الروسيه حتى الاول من
ابريل للتخلص من هواتفهم المحموله ايفون
والسبب هو مخاوف امنيه من اختراق وكاله
الاستخبارات الغربيه لهذه الاجهزه وتقول
الصحيفه ان القرار اتخذ خلال ندوه
للكراملين شارك فيها مسؤولون ضالعون في
السياسه الداخليه وصرح احدهم نصا انتهى
الامر بالنسبه لهواتف ايفون ارموها بعيدا
او اعطوها لاطفالكم على الجميع تغيير
هواتفهم في مارس وقيل ايضا انه ممكن ان
تقوم الاداره الرئاسيه بشراء هواتف امنه
جديده لموظفيها لتسهيل التخلي عن التك
نولوجيا الامريكيه ايفون كونها اكثر عرضه
للقرصنه وللتجسس من قبل الخبراء الغربيين
واقترح حضور في الاجتماع وفق الصحيفه ان
يمنح للمسؤولين هؤلاء هواتف تعمل بنظام
تشغيل اورورا الروسي او اندرويد الصيني
المتحدث باسم الكرملين سئل عن الموضوع
وقال ان هذه التقارير لا يمكن تاكيدها في
الوقت الراهن لكن صرح انه بكل الاحوال لا
يجب استخدام الهواتف الذكيه للاغراض
الرسميه يذكر ان الرئيس الروسي صرح سابقا
انه لا يمكن لا يملك هاتفا ذكيا والمتحدث
باسمه قال ان الرئيس يستخدم الدم الانترنت
من وقت لاخر فقط السؤال الان يا تمحور حول
التقارير عن منع الكرملين المسؤولين من
استخدام ايفون لمخاوف من تجسس لاي درجه
المخاوف في مكانها وهل فعلا للمخابرات
الغربيه القدره على التجسس عبر هواتف من
نوع معين دون ان غيرها او ربما هذه محاوله
من روسيا للانتقام من امريكا لاتهام موسكو
بالتدخل في انتخاباتها في عام 2016 خاصه
وان روسيا على موعد مع انتخاباتها
الرئاسيه في عام 2024
ومن الرياض ينضم الينا صانع المحتوى
التقني فيصل السيف اهلا بك استاذ فيصل
نعرف ان عمليه التجسس غالبا ما تاتي عبر
الشبكات التواصل الاجتماعي او عبر الشبكات
الاتصالات او المنصات لكن نريد ان نستوضح
منك هل فعلا يتم التجسس عبر جهاز الايفون
نفسه
مساكم الله بالخير ولجميع الساده
المشاهدين الامر ممكن تقنيا بشكل جدا كبير
ولكن ما حيكون من خلال الشركه الام
الصانعه للهواتف او من خلال نفس النظام
ولكن حيكون من خلال اطراف ثالثه شركات
متخصصه في هذه الامور من طرف ثالث بعضها
متواجد في امريكا وبالتالي نعم الامر
تقنيا ممكن قابليه انه هذا الامر يتطبق او
ما يتطبق هذا يرجع الى قوه الاوامر اللي
تطلع من الجهات المعنيه للحصول على
المعلومات من هذه الاجهزه الموضوع نقدر
نقوله بكل شفافيه
بتصير ليش لا
الخبر يقول انه ستستبدل نظام
روسي اخر ما هو هذا النظام وهل يمكن ان
يستخدم على ايفون نظام روسي
جميل الايفونات نفسها انه يكون عليها نظام
تشغيلي غير الاي او اس اللي هو حاليا
موجود عليها امر جدا مستبعد وما في قابليه
لهذا الامر كون انه الهاردوير الاعتاد
وايضا نفس البرامج التشغيليه
منسقه على بعض وبالتالي كيانهم موحد اما
لما نتكلم على انظمه روسيه بديله حاليا
موجوده على ارض الواقع بكثافه جدا عاليه
فهذا غير موجود ولكن ان تكلمنا على قابليه
الامن في امن المعلومات
ما جدي والامر واقعي بحيث انه اذا كانت
روسيا او نقدر نقول المسؤولين الروس من
وجهه نظري مهتمين لدرجه امان اعلى بان
يكون الانظمه والاجهزه اللي موجوده معاهم
تابعي لروسيا وهذا السيناريو ينطبق على اي
مكان واي دوله في العالم اذا انت قاعد
تستخدم تقنيه ليست محليه فبالتالي هذه
التقنيه وعدم تواجدها المحلي 100% يكون من
خلالها في نقدر نقول الا في مساله الامر
نعم يعني تعتبر ان الموضوع سياسي اكثر ما
هو تقني عن نفسي سياسي جدا لانه لو جينا
وشفنا اخر اربع سنوات من عام 2019 لما
بدات امريكا ضد هواوي الصينيه وبداوا
يتكلموا عن موضوع البيانات ومن وقتها
وكثير من القيود تضع على شركات تقنيه
صينيه واللي احنا نعرفه نذكر نفسنا بانه
الاقتصاد الرقمي الامريكي احد اكبر موارد
الاقتصاد العالمي بالنسبه لامريكا
والايرادات منه تيجي كثير من شبكات
التواصل الاجتماعي من اجهزه الانظمه
الجوالات الاندرويد
فبالتالي لما يكون في منافسه على شبكات
التواصل وبعدين حرب نشوفها ضد هواوي بلتها
تطلع من رقم واحد في الماركت من المبيعات
تنزل الى الارقام العشره من ناحيه
المبيعات بدل ما كانت في الصداره وايضا
بعدها لما شفنا على تيك توك وشبكات تواصل
اجتماعي يكون في نفس النموذج بانه يتم
اتهامات بالاختراق لهذه الشبكات حق
التواصل الاجتماعي
نعرف ان الامر سياسي بشكل واقعي قبل ما
يكون تقني فهي المعامله بالمثل زي ما
امريكا قالت عن الصين انه عندكم تقنيات
ننطقي
نعم لكن المخاوف شرعيه لانه حسب ما انت
تتكلم ان هناك ممكن ان يتم اختراق الاجهزه
الايفون لمسؤولين الروس وبالتالي هواجسهم
مشروعه
حوادث مشروع عليه كل الاطراف في المعادلات
التقنيه وما في احد يقدر يامن بجانب
التقني مليون في المئه لانه في شركات
متخصصه في امور
تحدثت السلطات الروسيه عن استبدال هواتف
ايفون بهواتف امنه ما المقصود بالهواتف
الامنه
جميل اذا كان في هواتف نقدر نقول بانظمه
تشغيليه اقل وزنا وعتادا وكفاءه من
الاشياء اللي نشوفها في الهواتف الذكيه قد
ننتقل الى هواتف تعتمد على الشبكات فقط
لاتمام الاتصالات وليس بتصفح الانترنت
والبيانات وارسال واستقبال البيانات من
خلالها هذه احد الخيارات المطروحه
وبالتالي هذا الامر اصلا موجود في الشبكات
المحليه لكن يعني لن تكون هواتف ذكيه ومن
منا او من
يستغني عن الهواتف الذكيه لهواتف اقل
تقنيه اخف النقطه اللي انت ذكرتيها جدا
المهمه فبالتالي اذا الواحد قاعد يستخدم
الجوال لاسباب هذا لا يمنع انه يستخدم
جوال ثاني لاسباب اخرى موجوده عنده ونعرف
انه في جهات رسميه لما تيجي انت تروح
دوامك في هذه الجهه الرسميه تتجنب ادخال
لابتوبات الى الحين تتجنب ادخال لاب توب
غير مصلح يكون موجود في هذه المنظومه نفس
الامر ينطبق على الاجهزه الجوال فانت عندك
لاب توب ثاني وعندك انظمه ثانيه ولكن ما
تدخل معاك في الدوام الا اشياء محدده وما
قالوا انه لا يستخدم الافراد جبرا ما احد
يستخدم اي نظام الا الروسي
من الرياض كان معنا صانع المحتوى التقني
فيصل سيف شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]